what up army
I'm Greg I'm John Cooke we're gonna
watch BTS being extra AF in America yeah
as flip as family friendly yeah this is
a top works here video request from the
hottie from ivory Natalie Dory we are
going to watch this right now guys at
our patreon page do weekly Q&A is TV
show reaction stream along several
reaction highlights included but if all
that John does music video reactions
weekly at our patreon page and you best
believe a lot of that is tape hop mmm
before you know it real rejects will
become a kpop reaction channel we will
sort gold with millions of subscribers
and not a single monetization in any of
our videos well it's to this is gonna
make 45 cents from that shared revenue
yeah
[Music]
do you date we want to focus on our
career so focus in our prayer yeah so
now it's very hard today so we so yeah
we we go favorite teacher what's your
fave on yourself mine is my smile I love
your fingers and skipping leg day your
world
oh my god show in the world music use
like in a big in this universe so it's
in keeping the same star line so like if
you if you unless you watch the previous
videos you might not understand shop
about airplane part two which is
obviously Jay hopes the follow-up to the
song so yes so what we do is put this
song in the album and what's kind of
something else that you'd like to
accomplish this year everybody it is a
much later but we need to get you guys a
bunch of famous you no no no yes I love
when you finish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
did that guy needs to Joe yeah me no
really
get ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
turn
[Music]
that's the version look at all these
American people they no no that's like a
Living magazine go really is weird games
that have been played
oh [ __ ] who's got a straight face he's
that guy this is the hardest try not to
laugh challenge No so Farley suga is one
a real dance yep I can who is this
editor and how do we hire sounds
American when he speaks all that friends
manage their time to resent America
[Music]
[Music]
they're playing part two of my favorites
oh no there's holes
you're welcome
Larry David never wins especially not in
South Korea or in America uh that wasn't
a hug I'm just getting the door for you
oh yeah homoerotic innuendo is make for
the best kind of comedy always
especially by guys who spend a lot of
time in close proximity with one another
they've already thought were gay cabin
fever mana gets intense RRM like when he
speaks English sometimes it sounds like
a person who learned English and there
are times where it sounds America I
think it's just the confident delivery
yeah when he talks he got I can't do it
I can't avoid it's just like punctuation
that he has at the end of every sentence
he says so want to focus on our career
yeah yeah yeah he does seem to have like
a more boys clothes petite yeah he seems
to have more confidence walking around
in English and just a broader vocab I
think overall sexy brain oh you saw my
words I feel like Natalie's told us in
the past that you know RM was
responsible for kind of helping them all
learn English and stuff so she Natalie
talked to you in private
that's right she keeps like close tabs
on BTS she gives me own Intel you know
talks to me in private - oh yeah she
sends me a lot of pigs ah a lot of dick
pigs
oh wow the one that she receives from
other people yes like oh you gotta see
this one where is them to me can you put
these on to the end of each video I'm
always like goof oh oh oh hey guys
definitely Lebanese yeah that's
impressive that you can tell this I can
tell all races except one that's a black
people it's happening
conversation you know we're being extra
- in America oh yeah what I loved about
this is every once in a while you know I
like watching celebrity game shows from
the American talk show host of like
Fallon and James Corden you get these
rather self-serious celebs to like
participate in these wacky ass games
sometimes I get the impression that they
don't like doing this like they should
be taking more seriously or something I
never get that with these this whole
okay no matter what weird ass game it is
that they have them playing they fully
commit and participate and always want
to have fun and make each other laugh
and are always loose and engaged yeah
and I love that about them because as
intense of a work ethic as they have and
as super star sensations as they are no
matter the game they never seem like
they're above it they always get into it
always games with the host no matter who
the host is way yeah I love that about
them they're always loose and having a
great time and don't take each other
serious oh yeah
when I feel like in this phase of our
journey through BTS you know we've seen
a whole bunch of the music videos and
we've seen a lot about their
perseverance and they're come up and
stuff so it's fun to now just sit back
and watch him if goof around and have a
good time too because I don't know yeah
their energy is just so infectious you
everyone in the room agrees yeah I just
want to see all these collaborations
come to light that's the thing now is
like we need a la Charlie puth know why
my wretched heart turns into like this
old-school New York and the red Mustang
you know his rap monster because its
voice goes like really deep yeah yeah
yeah he has like kids Rodney Dangerfield
yeah yeah yeah the Rodney Dangerfield
caveman I can't get no respect that's
why he's always rapping about how hard
he works because he's just trying to get
the respect I just hate that when he
speaks English it sounds better than
when I speak English well you know hit
him up
you can connect over your love of
friends
maybe that's how you should have learned
the language could I be
that's good
I bet AR I would love that joke Oh what
on a t-shirt send it to him I bet he'll
want to meet you are M messages me all
the time he says we pics so you get wrap
messages from rap monster crow tip ticks
crow today I found some more hope you
enjoy love are ya anyway anyway this was
great this was Natalie sad that she sent
me a shoot when she when she messaged me
about hold on a second Natalie said you
know John if you need yawn while I'm
talking you could at least cover your
enormous mouth Natalie said the editing
in this video is done like this on
purpose to make it very awkward and very
funny the actual clips interviews aren't
offer at all it's just the way the
editing is done so glad you said that
because I would have been like oh my
this is not who I expected at all I
signed up for it I want them to be
serious I thought this was great guys
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to FTW 17 they are a verified channel
for the win you guys can also click our
notification Bell also guys go check us
out on patreon and Natalie I hope you
have a fun time in England don't get too
drunk
keep those pics coming and I'll see you
when I see you
crota it's better better punch line than
crow tits what could be a better punch
line than that Gregory Greg monster
Natta
wait wait wait Natalie there's got to be
a way to work Natalie's name into a BTS
members name but what is it a few
moments later alright alright
I was thinking Natalie
erm
I was thinking net cook not cook oh
that's nice yeah yeah
sugar Lee we won